er hat steine geworfen als junger spund
und revolutionärer straßenkämpfer in
frankfurt er hat stein ins rollen
gebracht als einer der originellsten und
überraschendsten politiker denen der
bundesrepublik deutschland je wirkten
und da ist heute besorgt dass ein traum
von einem friedlichen und wirtschaftlich
blühenden europaplatz wenn die jetzigen
verantwortlichen die historische aufgabe
nicht stemmen um den kurs nicht
verlassen den er als holzweg sie dass
joschka fischer die schweiz also just
unser land dabei als modell für das
europa seiner träume sieht das macht
deutschlands ehemaligen außenminister
und vize-kanzler zum doppelt spannenden
gast bei uns darum sage ich
herr fischer doppelt herzlich willkommen
bei uns im studio vielen dank und herr
hand aufs herz juckt es das einmal
politik joschka fischer nicht manchmal
wieder wenn wie letzte woche in paris am
klimagipfel weltpolitische weichen
gestellt werden werden sie da nicht
gerne wieder an den schalthebeln der
macht dabei nein das liegt hinter mir
das müssen sie einfach so glauben ist so
ja konnten sich aber es ist ein grüner
die welt muss geheim
es macht ja andere es ist ja nicht so
dass man nicht ersetzbar ist und andere
generationen andere zahlt machen sie es
gleich gut oder sie haben auch schon
angetönt dass sowohl richtig kernige
figuren wie sie eine waren ein bisschen
rarer geworden sind nur paris ist doch
sehr gut gelaufen und ich mal wenn man
sich die umstände anschaut wichtig war
es schon kann man sehr wichtig kann man
französischen diplomatie nur gratulieren
und dem außenminister laurent fabius
aber auch dem französischen
staatspräsident dahinter steckt nicht
nur die aktuelle konferenz arbeit
sondern monate der vorbereitung
das ist schon sehr gut gemacht worden
kommt es auf die köpfe in den kulissen
darauf an wie gut einer ist hängt das
ergebnis dann von der fähigkeit dieser
spitzenpolitiker wirklich ein so
verhandlungssituationen spiele das ohne
jeden zweifel hinein aber nicht nur der
spitzenpolitiker sondern auch die
qualität der diplomaten und um das
gleich auch zu sagen die schweiz verfügt
hier ebenfalls über
vor ragendes diplomatisches personal auf
den verschiedensten positionen viele
bewundern im deutschsprachigen europa
den politiker fischer bis heute andere
tragen ihn vermutlich bis heute nicht
über den weg aber kaum einer würde
bestreiten dass sie einer wahren der
immer wieder innovationen in die politik
gemacht gebracht hat um nicht zu sagen
dass die politik aufgemischt haben mit
tabubrüchen und weil viele heute ja
sagen die politik ist irgendwie
verstockt kommt nicht weiter möchte ich
zuerst mit ihnen darüber reden ob die
politik wieder neue tabubrüche bräuchte
und wie das bei ihnen funktioniert hat
da schauen wir kurz ein bisschen zurück
sie haben als erster grüner minister in
deutschland im bundesland hessen er 1984
bei der vereidigung der guten alten
tradition des hauses buchstäblich den
schub gegeben
wir sehen das auch auf einer fotografie
ja sie sind total protokoll wird mit
turnschuhen zur vereidigung angetreten
hatten sie keine besseren schule oder
was nötig war ein ordentlicher diese
trete und habe ich extra gekauft zwar
eine lange debatte in der grünen
landtagsfraktion und war eine meinung
dann der ich mich auch angeschlossen
habe
das muss sein die grünen damals zum
ersten mal in die regierung mit verrats
vorwurf behaftet und alles wollten damit
symbolisieren dass wir noch verbindungen
haben zu den ökologischen
protestbewegungen das nicht aufgegeben
haben und die waren brandneue vom regal
über haben brandneue vom regal halt in
wiesbaden in der fußgängerzone habe ich
die am tag vorher gekauft und danach
auch nicht wieder getragen aber der
ministerpräsident börner dort werben
bisschen gestresst
der war ein bisschen stressig fans ja
ehrlich gesagt auch leicht peinlich weil
das ganze drumherum
aber das musste sein da mussten alle
beteiligten durch das heißt politik hat
viel mit der kraft der symbole halt zu
tun sehr viel und das symbol war wir
sind nicht wie ihr angepassten alten
säcke waren auch höhere säcke dabei aber
ich meine schauen sieht man darf auch
nicht überschätzen klar diese symbole
die wirken sie
lange noch heute in die natur ist sie
übrigens 30 jahre letzte woche war der
jahrestag 30 jahre her und sie reden
immer noch darüber da sehen sie mal ja
andere auch der ton so minimal dass
hafte die einander immer eine rolle dass
haftet an den füßen
trotzdem auch vom naturell her
vermutlich mal waren sie der frechdachs
war die nicht mehr gemacht die anderen
zu vollziehen
es war schon ich langweile mich sehr
ungarn und wenn ich anfange mich zu
langweilen habe ich schon in der schule
in der regel angefangen etwas
anzustellen
und das galt natürlich auch für das
parlament also ich hasse dich zu sehr
weh da zu sitzen und langweiligen reden
folgen zu müssen oder nicht folgen zu
müssen sich einfach zu langweilen und
aber ich würde das mit den tabubrüchen
nicht überpointiert weil das war eine
zeit damals das war auch ein übergang
heute regt sich über die grünen niemand
mehr auf heute trägt selbst der
siemens-chef keine krawatte mehr
das war damals undenkbar das heißt es
war eine andere zeit und dann war
manches mittlerweile hoch
veränderungsbedürftig und solche
auftritte haben die veränderungen dann
gebracht heute ist dass falls sie hier
in gesprächen sollten melden sie es mir
dann stelle ich ja verwirren und so
würden und sein persönliches schieße
dann mit papierkram fragen aus dem
people -magazin aber so weit sind wir
noch nicht sondern bei politik und
symbolen und der frechheit
ich glaube als sie dann junger minister
waren sie hatten auch keine mühe die
alten verdienten beamten die da für sie
arbeiteten zu riskieren wenn es sein
musste da habe ich auch nach der
parlament altlasten gegründet es war
dringend nötig weil altlasten war damals
ein großes umweltproblem ist es
teilweise heute noch und da musste man
eine eigene abteilung dafür schaffen
das war auch die möglichkeit leute zu
versetzen ich gebe es offen zu wir
hatten da teilweise versetzung bedarf
und weil sie die schule angesprochen
habe
da haben sie auch so gelangweilt dass
sie dann mal schnell von der schule
geflogen
sie sind der typische so schule apfel
ich mit meinen lehrern kann mich nicht
so richtig übereinander und dann also
weg von der schule dann eine lehre als
fotograf hat auch nicht so lange genau
da war wieder das autoritätsproblem mit
dem lehrherrn nach einem jahr war
schluss und das war für sie immer klar
die alten chefs hatten das nicht
verdient dass sie dort nein es war für
mich nicht klar so ich kam mit allen gut
aus solange man mich so namen wie ich
war wenn mir aber eine anfing
vorschriften zu machen oder mir meinte
anordnung geben zu können ohne mir zu
erklären warum oder wenn ich andere
auffassung war die diskussion verweigert
hat dann senkte ich sehr schnell die
hörner und dann ging es meistens ganz
schnell zu hause mit den eltern sie
kommen aus einem ganz katholischen
haushalt war es auch ziemlich auf
konfrontation oder gar nicht mal so um
später dann in der pubertät ja doch link
dem vater als wo es war messdiener auch
ja so richtig dass wolle das programm
einer anatolischen grund ich bin ein
flüchtlingskind muss man in diesen
zeiten ja betonen da sehen sie mal was
man in deutschland nicht links kind
alles werden
das verspricht viel weil ihre eltern
waren aus ungarn dann weggezogen und sie
erinnern sich nicht an um ganz sicher
bin ich bin in deutschland geboren ja
aber es spielt natürlich eine große
rolle
das heißt ich bin aufgewachsen in einem
familiären milieu in dem es ein daheim
gab daheim war ungarn dass ich nicht
kannte eine fantasiewelt für das kind
und eine sprache die ich auch nicht
verstand bei der eltern waren bilingual
die küche war anders als im schwäbischen
das war eine österreichische ungarische
küche ist er lag bei monat sehr gut
gekocht aber all das lässt mich an wie
es für heute für zuwanderer kinder der
zweiten generation in deutschland oder
in der schweiz ist wie man sich fühlt
und so richtig zu hause fühlt man sich
dann nicht und man vergisst ja heute
nach dem krieg war nicht alles eitel
sonnenschein
inzwischen den alteingesessenen und
zuwanderern häuser waren alles deutsche
ja aber da gab es katholiken der gab es
protestanten die fronten des
dreißigjährigen krieges existierten dort
noch das wurde durch diese
flüchtlingsaufnahme verändert am anfang
gab es da auch erhebliche konflikte und
lange fühlte man sich auch nicht
wirklich da zu hause ist dieses
grundgefühl lange dann das ganze leben
geblieben so ganz zu hause bin ich was
mit uns nach deutschland dass man zu
hause und habe keine partei sie waren
der wichtigste mann aber nicht so
richtig dass da kein partei mensch ich
folgten parteimensch was hat sie jetzt
in die politik getrieben
die politik ja das hat mich schon warum
über die vergangenheit sprechen als kind
fasziniert es war noch die gute alte
zeit in anführungszeichen vor fernsehen
gab es noch nicht und da gab es dann die
sonntags besucher und dann separierten
sich schnell nach der an der kaffeetafel
die frauen von den männern im ändern
2000 an der einen ecke und politisierten
und da fühlte ich mich immer hingezogen
das interessierte mich interessiert die
geschichte ist er stark
also mich hat die politik zur politik
und auch ein bestimmter inhalt gab seine
utopie wollten sie die welt richtig und
schnell verändern sollte das war damals
mit der langsam
das war das war dann schon später das
war schon ergebnis aber wenn sie die
frage nach dem ursprung wie kam ich in
die politik dann war es eigentlich eine
recht früh neigung und der faszination
und das ziel war aber dinge verändern
dieser politische weg hat dann über
viele und ganz spannende stationen
geführt und auf einige werden wir auch
genauer blicken können aber zuerst
möchte ich herzhaft den sprung machen zu
der vision oder zu dem anliegen für das
sie heute ihr herz blutvergießen in
büchern und in artikeln nämlich zur
frage europa sie haben
zusammen mit bundeskanzler schröder
immer vorwärts gepresst in richtung
eines großen europas den der türkei auch
den weg geben nach europa sie haben
gesagt davon hängt die zukunft unseres
kontinenten ab damit herr außenminister
ag sind sie gelinde gesagt ein bisschen
gegen den trend heute nur bin ich mir
nicht so sicher wenn ich mir anschaue
die pilgerfahrten die neuerdings wieder
nach istanbul und ankara unternommen
werden damit die flüchtlingsfrage
gemeinsam angegangen werden kann
ich glaube es wäre einfacher gewesen man
hätte damals 2007 merkel und sarkozy die
politik von uns fortgeführt es wäre
einfacher voll aber die türkei nach
europa holen diesen ort der wert der
demokratie und die türkei jetzt wird
regiert von einem autokraten namens
erdogan lässt die schmucke garde dem es
durch eine organisation die alles
bekämpft was uns wichtig ist
frauenrechte demokratie falles
möchten sie die türkei wirklich
mitnehmen die türkei eu-mitglied wird
weiß ich nicht genauso wenig wie ich
weiß ob die schweiz jedes eu mitglied
wird
es ist auch egal entscheidend ist dass
die türkei für die europäischen
interessen von überragender bedeutung
ist für die in der gesamtregion wird
europa ohne oder gar gegen die türkei
sehr wenig erreichen oder fast nichts
erreichen können
umgekehrt haben wir ein interesse an
guten beziehungen zu der türkei was sie
gerade angesprochen haben die
entwicklung von präsident erdogan und
die entwicklung in der türkei macht die
sache natürlich sehr sehr schwierig
deswegen wäre es richtiger gewesen man
hätte den prozess den wir damals
begonnen haben wir mit gerd schröder
meine ich damit den hätte man fortführen
sollen ich glaube dann wäre auch manche
entwicklungen der türkei anders gelaufen
europa hat eine große rolle gespielt die
türkei auf den einen demokratischen
rechtsstaatlichen kurs zu bringen
und als man 2007 an erdogan die tür vor
der nase zugeschlagen hat kam seine
orientierung richtung nahe osten mit all
den folgen die das dann im einzelfall
mit sich bringen die ich genauso
kritisch sehe wie sie aber es führt kein
weg dran vorbei
auch jetzt noch auch jetzt mehr denn je
es führt kein weg daran vorbei den
mühseligen weg gehen zu versuchen die
beziehungen zur türkei zu verbessern
aber war das nicht ein weg den
zweifellos sehr gut informierte und
fähige spitzenpolitiker wie sie und
schröder voran gepusht haben aber die
bevölkerungen werden mitgegangen dass es
zu fremd die türkei dann kommen ein
großer zahl leute aus der islamischen
kultur die detektive vollkommen während
doch nicht mitgekommen hier also wenn
ich mir anschaue die türkische
zuwanderung in deutschland ist eine der
erfolgreichsten zuwanderungen die wir
haben wenn sich das einem berufen
anschauen sind nicht nur
in der wirtschaft sondern vor allen
dingen auch anwälte schriftsteller sehr
viele kunstschaffende von dem
gesichtspunkt her kann man nicht sagen
dass das eine immigration ist die große
probleme mit sich gebracht hat und auf
der anderen seite die europäisierung der
türkei liegt im europäischen interesse
je mehr die türkei je enger sie an
europa angebunden ist je länger die
verbindung sind desto besser dabei sie
ist nummer
schauen sie das problem in der
außenpolitik ist nicht das man sich
wünschen kann welche nachbarn man hat
man hat die nachbarn die man hat und
dass die definition der nachbarschaft
ist das bleibt so das heißt die türkei
ist in einer überragenden geopolitischen
situation für europäische interessen im
nahen osten im schwarzmeerraum
kaukasusgebiet bis zentralasien und eine
entfremdung der türkei würde enorme
kosten mit sich bringen und risiken aber
zwischen einer entfremdung und wirklich
sagen richtig nahe
also ich verschärft jetzt meine
argumentation noch als rumänien und
bulgarien 2007 dann beitraten und die
vorphase daran sie ja aktive
außenminister haben ja auch viele
gedacht länder die noch solche probleme
mit korruption haben und wo der staat
nicht nach einer richtig guten
demokratischen manier funktioniert wenn
man dir einnimmt dann verbessert sich
die eu als hort der wirklichen
lupenreinen demokratie also dem begriff
der lokalen demokratie den mache ich mir
nicht zu eigen er hat ein anderes
dann wollen wir nicht mit seinen
begriffen reden einer funktionierenden
demokratie werden diesen ländern stellen
wir uns vor die wären heute nicht
mitglied der europäischen union
sie wären heute schon zankapfel zwischen
russland und der eu
das muss man sehen also die in russland
das wieder auf einflusszone setzt und
auch vom militärischen aktionen nicht
zurückschreckt um seine interessen
durchzusetzen
nachbarschaft würde da sofort wieder ein
ein ort der instabilität das gut dass
man das im trockenen hat sagen sie
ich sage nicht es ist nicht im trockenen
aber es sind mitglieder der europäischen
union und die eu kann dort einfluss
nimmt auch einfluss und ist alles andere
als einfach
aber das ist in der definition dieses
europas es sind nicht nur die gleichen
und die gleich gesunden wie groß soll
das ihr vereinigtes europa werden über
den balkan braucht man nicht zu streiten
über die türkei kann man und muss man
auch streiten ob die türken jemals
mitglied der eu werden das liegt in den
nebeln der zukunft aber dass wir enge
beziehungen zu ihnen unterhalten müssen
und dass wir versuchen müssen einen
positiven einfluss zu nehmen so dass
sich die türkei in die richtung eines
modernen islamischen geprägten staates
entwickelt einer demokratie dass das
recht dort gilt dass ich eine positive
wirtschaftliche entwicklung macht dass
sie ein faktor der stabilität und nicht
der instabilität wird daran müssen wir
jedes interesse machen dass ihre
nachfolger im außenministerium und dem
bundeskanzleramt gut gemacht es gut ich
hätte mir nur gewünscht wie gesagt dass
dieser prozess nicht unterbrochen worden
wäre aber besser spät als nie recht gebe
ich ihnen allerdings gerne und sofort
bei der überlegen die sie irgendwo
niedergeschrieben haben dass europa
einer der besten orte auf unserem
planeten ist das sieht man daran dass
millionen die flüchten müssen genau
hierher kommen wollen dass es sich ein
beleg für ihre these des europas der der
werte
die frage ist einfach gibt es dann nicht
doch wieder zwangsläufig grenzen der
solidarität
im irdischen jammertal gibt es immer
irgendwelche grenzen aber das wesen der
politik ist zu versuchen sie auszudehnen
zu optimieren und auch durchzusetzen
wenn es nötig ist
ich denke es ist eine große leistung die
gerade jetzt
deutschland und einige andere
europäische länder gebracht haben
die kriegsflüchtlinge fall dinge aus
syrien aufzunehmen und ich meine man
muss sich mal vorstellen die menschen
dort haben die alternative entweder vom
islamisch staat massakriert zu werden
oder von den fast bomben von assad oder
zu verraten in irgendwelchen lagern in
der jordanischen wüste und dabei wurden
ihnen noch die gelder gekürzt
auch deutschland hat seine beiträge in
der vergangenheit reduziert
das führte dazu dass die menschen dort
von 0 von 50 eurocent pro kopf und tag
leben mussten
schulpflichtige kinder seit jahren haben
keine chance zur schule zu gehen was
irgendwie sie machen was würde ich
machen wenn wir da in diesen lagern
setzen und sehen wie die kinder
heranwachsen und keine chance haben ein
vernünftiges lebensmittel würden uns
auch auf den weg machen und wo würden
wir hingehen
dort wo wir vermuten dass es frieden und
stabilität eine perspektive geben ist
eine menschliche reaktion und und ich
sage ihnen als als kind von von
heimatvertriebenen kann ich diese
vergangenheit nicht ausblenden
viele er kommt viel in mir wieder gut
meinen dem menschen zumal auch im grünen
und linken lager sagen ja wir müssen
offen sein aber selbst viele linke
verweisen jetzt darauf man kann nicht
alle nehmen weil sonst verändert sich
die art wie wir hier leben so sehr dass
es eben nicht mehr dieser hort der wert
dieses recht ist der mann der
französische intellektuelle der mit che
guevara gekämpft hat schreibt melodie
fragt lob der grenzen nur mit grenzen
können wir die werte eben auch bewährt
und das in einer in in der ära der
globalisierung entdecken wir die grenzen
das halte ich für ziemliche illusion
vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass wir
die innerdeutsche grenze
sie hatten die ja heftig befestigt war
wo geschossen wurde wo minenfelder waren
und alles getan wurde um menschen an der
bewegung zu hindern
aber ich glaube das wird nicht
funktionieren was wir jetzt erleben ist
doch dass globalisierung nicht mehr
einbahnstraße ist dass wir im westen
güter exportieren und gutes geld
verdienen was völlig legitim ist aber es
ist eine mär bahnstraße es kommen auch
menschen es kommen flüchtlinge jetzt
kommen die konflikte und es wäre weise
sich vorher darum zu kümmern und nicht
zu warten bis die probleme an der
haustüre angekommen sind dass syrien
kannte man seit vielen jahren
da hätte man vorher agieren müssen und
können
ich denke keiner will gerne seine heimat
verlassen
das ist sie glauben syrien hätte man bei
frühe intervention etwas machen können
das ist nicht so schlimm wird haben wir
so für mich ist der irak das klassische
beispiel einer verfehlten einer falschen
intervention syrien aber ist für mich
das klassische beispiel der konsequenzen
der negativen konsequenzen einer nicht
stattgefundenen intervention beim irak
waren sie noch außenminister haben dem
amerikanischen verteidigungsminister in
münchen die ratingwissen rumsfeld die
leviten gelesen gesagt i am not
convinced also ziemlich öffentlich und
jetzt für syrien ist obama zuständigen
politiker der in gewissen er steht ist
ja jetzt zu zögernd auf ich finde um es
zusammenzufassen aber zu zögern
es ist nicht um die intervention mit
bodentruppen gegangen
aber wenn der amerikanische präsidenten
rote linie zieht und daraus nicht
wirklich etwas folgt ist das signal ein
verheerender gesagt hat chemie waffen
sind die rote linie und dann hat er
nicht gehandelt werde haben sie eine
erklärung getraute sich nicht ist ja ich
denke dass in washington aus
nachvollziehbaren gründen nämlich
rückzug aus irak und afghanistan
beendigung dieser
militärischen engagement das das die
dominante rolle war und um gottes willen
nicht wieder rein
es gab ja damals kräfte der
verteidigungsminister der damalige und
hillary clinton die damalige
außenministerin war anderer meinung ich
habe mehr diese meinung von den beiden
kritischen stimmen zugelegt die dort für
ein energisches vorgehen plädiert haben
aber sich nicht durchsetzen können denen
die ihre vision eines großen vereinigten
europa kritisieren antworten sie oft das
falscheste was man machen konnte ist
eben ein europa jetzt zu schaffen wie
sie im letzten im sommer dann passiert
ist wo der norden mit harter peitsche
von dann die deutschen gegen den süden
die griechen vorgegangen ist das hielten
sie für ganz verheerend wie man da
versucht hat sozusagen einem ganzen volk
den zähler einzustellen ja ich glaube so
funktioniert das nicht
die griechen wissen selber welche
riesenprobleme sie haben und diese lösen
müssen
danach wegen der noch wegen europa
sondern für sich selbst
das sind ja nicht probleme die über
nacht gekommen sind auch die italiener
kennen ihre probleme nur zu gut und
andere südländer man ja auch im norden
so gab zeiten da ging es frankreich sehr
guten und sehr schlecht deswegen haben
wir damals die notwendige reform
sozialstaats reformen
arbeitsmarktreformen unter der gerhard
schröder gemacht aber man kann das nicht
sozusagen mit einem autoritären von
außen aufgezwungene kurs erreichen
auf der anderen seite muss man auch
sehen dass in der eurozone eben auch
dann materielle solidarität gefragt war
also ich denke eine andere ton eine
andere umgang miteinander hätte da sehr
viel bewirkt vor allem am anfang hatten
sie es für wirklich gefährlich dass man
sich so zerstreitet dass das zeugs nicht
mehr zu kitten ist oder ist es einfach
eine atmosphärische rein das
das problem ist hielt sich ihnen an der
schweiz illustrieren damit sie als
nicht-eu-mitglied wissen nachvollziehen
können das wäre so wendy welchen und die
deutschschweizer plötzlich bitterbös
übereinander herfallen würden nicht so
die üblichen das übliche was man kennt
allein ist nicht allein lassen
das gehört dazu sondern so richtig
bitter böse und hart konfrontativ da
würde plötzlich so mancher sagen hey
hatte ich weiß noch eine zukunft als
mehr nationalstaat als ein gemeinwesen
das auf vernunft und kompromiss gründet
und das ist in etwa das problem auch in
europa die renationalisierung das
plötzlich wieder in nationalen
kategorien gedacht wird das ist für mich
das gefährlichste was uns da sind wir
glaube ich an einen ganz interessanten
punkt weil sie wirklich sagen dass
europa das sie wollen und dass sie auch
schon zum teil realisiert sehen sei ein
bisschen wie die schweiz verschiedene
gruppen verschiedene kulturen vor allem
die aber schon richtig zusammen gehören
aber viele andere denken natürlich in
europa soweit sind ja nicht wir wollen
höchstens ein europa der vaterländer ja
wie gesagt wir wollen wir nicht zusammen
und jeder schweizer geschichte anja
hätten sich die kräfte durchgesetzt
hätten sich die innerschweizer kantone
durchgesetzt
1847 die die souveränität bei den
kantonen halten wollten also nicht dass
die schweiz der nicht vaterländer
sondern eher der heimatkanton meine
luzern brach beispiel bezweifle ich das
ist die moderne schweiz heute noch gebe
weil im 19 jahrhundert führte an einer
gewissen zentralisierung von macht
schweiz ist heute immer noch sehr
dezentral aber eine gewisse
zentralisierung in wirtschafts
steuerfragen und vor allen dingen auch
der außenpolitik und der verteidigung
und auch eine veränderung der
abstimmungsmodus dass es keine feste
bindung mehr gab der kantonsvertreter
dass sie frei waren in ihrem mandat
alter spielt eine entscheidende rolle
also das heißt das entstehen von bern
für das überleben der schweiz wie wir
sie heute kennen
und ich füge hinzu auch leben das werden
einige überraschen die uns zu schauen
und die denken die schweiz ist das
genaue gegenteil zur eu dass der
erfahrene politiker joschka fischer sagt
die schweiz ist eigentlich das einzige
modell der historischen zwei modelle die
schweiz und die usa
der usa es für uns glaube ich nicht
wirkliches modell weil wir nicht eine
sprache haben da ist die schweiz anders
da gibt es deutsch italienisch und die
roman schmücken wir jetzt verzeichnen
jetzt auch gibt es auch aber und dennoch
auch die unterschiedlichen kulturen die
mit der sprache verbunden sind
wir sagen schweizer freunde der
röstigraben wäre so tief wie immer und
da hätte sich nichts wirklich geändert
und dennoch funktioniert die schweiz als
ein gemeinwesen sogar sehr gut und mit
unterschiedlichen kulturen
unterschiedlichen sprachen das finde ich
das faszinierende das ist die
europäische situation wenn auch größer
andere dimension
und das sagen sie den europäern in
diskussionen wie ich gesehen habe
es gibt die schweiz wir können das auf
diesem modell machen oder versuchen und
man wird das ein oder andere also ich
keine eins zu eins zu übertragen sondern
ein vorbild im sinne ist funktioniert da
sagen jetzt aber viele selbst solche die
sagen das ist plausibel und
wahrscheinlich historisch vielleicht
auch ganz gescheit was sie sagen aber
man versucht die politiker versuchen
dieses europa hinter dem rücken der
völker der bevölkerungen zu bilden
die wollen das halt eigentlich nicht
stimmt das mag sein aber wie es ist es
europa überhaupt entstanden
die eu ist die antithese zum
nationalismus die eu wäre nie
wirklichkeit geworden wenn es diese
schreckliche erste hälfte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts nicht gegeben
hätte mit zwei weltkriegen revolutionen
diktaturen einem holocaust und diese
dieser horror erfahrung
der ersten hälfte des 20 jahrhunderts
hat die europäer dazu gebracht zu sagen
das muss anders werden und es wurde dann
anders das jetzt in frage zu stellen
das hielte ich für extrem kurzsichtig
das wurde anders zwar nicht gegründet
auf volksbefragung sondern es waren im
wesentlichen die europäischen eliten die
diese konsequent wenigsten churchill hat
ja seine berühmte zürcher rede gehalten
aber da kann sie auch als grüner
politiker damit leben manchmal muss die
elite vorangehen und wenn es die anderen
nicht merken vielleicht umso besser ich
hab ich da als grüner schwierigkeiten ja
das doch eine wunderbare alternative
partei alles ja ja ja aber ist nicht
immer so erfolgreich gewesen dieses
modell bisschen all its muss also dann
kann auch gut sein das heißt es muss
schauen sie meine haltung zu europa war
immer sehr klar und ich bin in
wahlkämpfen permanent unterwegs gewesen
und ich wurde gewählt
aber auch dort wo ich nicht direkt
angetreten bei den landtagswahlkämpfen
und selbst die kommunalwahl kämpfen
spielte das thema eine rolle
also war nicht so dass das nicht das
stimmt wiederum man hätte diese
geschichte kann alle wurden gewählt
obwohl sie nie klar euro pro
europäischen position hatten also die
these dass nur die direkte demokratie
legitimation schafft die teile ich nicht
die wahlen schaffen diese legitimation
auch jetzt möchte ich gerne wie die in
den reden über terrorismus als wie viele
befürchten tödliche gefahr für die
demokratie seit den blutigen anschlägen
von paris ist ganz frankreich schockiert
aber eigentlich auch ganz europa und die
dringlichkeit dieses themas ist richtig
wieder auf die agenda gekommen bevor wir
aber über terrorismus heute reden möchte
ich noch einmal nutzen die tatsache dass
sie als akteur ganz vorne
schon mehrere jahrzehnte der geschichte
ihres landes beobachten konnten worunter
auch das abdriften einer revolutionären
jugend in den terror der roten armee
fraktion der völlig klar sie haben sich
davon distanziert sie sind diesen weg
nicht gegangen aber sie haben jetzt
beobachtet er kann man sagen auch wenn
man nicht in den terrorismus selber
abgerutscht ist es hat sie damals bei
diesen straßenkämpfen in frankfurt schon
auch ein bisschen erschüttert diese
erfahrung von gewalt und gegengewalt auf
den straßen ja aber ehrlicherweise muss
man sagen die protestbewegung der nicht
angehört habe hat von anfang an riesen
fehler gemacht die bedeutung des rechts
und die verpflichtung auf gewaltfreiheit
nicht wirklich erkannt zu haben und
ernst genommen zu haben
darin sehe ich den größten fehler und
das führte dann in diese abschüssige
richtung den höhepunkt an der terror der
rafah sie ist ja immer geschrieben wir
wollten gerechtigkeit da wir haben das
recht nicht verstanden warum ich denke
was jungen leuten schwer klarzumachen
ist was man aber unbedingt versuchen
muss klar zu machen ist letztendlich
geht es darum die herrschaft des rechts
zu haben das heißt dass rechts
förmliches verfahren verpflichtung auf
die gewaltfreiheit verpflichtungen auf
das staatliche gewaltmonopol im
interesse aller es im interesse eines
friedlichen zusammenlebens im interesse
von gerechtigkeit und insofern wenn uns
das wenn wir uns anschauen
die lage in frankreich ist sehr sehr
schwierig die zustände im bus und all
das aber wir haben auf der anderen seite
natürlich heute eine andere eine viel
größere gefahr der verführung in der
terror wie viele hunderte oder gar
tausende junger europäer muslimischen
glaubens wurden vom islam zum start
angezogen rekrutiert haben sich
rekrutieren lassen und
das ist eine sehr große herausforderung
wobei ich eines hinzufügen möchte
terrorist eine taktik meistens eine
taktik die schwächere militärisch
schwächere an wenn die da die die
entscheidende herausforderung ist die
idee die dahinter steckt wenn man
gewinnen will muss man diese bekämpfen
und da finde ich hat europa eine
riesenchance
bei es geht um eine auseinandersetzung
im islam machen uns da nicht falsche
vorstellung und ich sehe nicht dass in
einem überschaubaren zeitraum der
sunnitische islam im nahen osten eine
wirkliche reform aus sich selbst heraus
hervorbringen kann und lieber in europa
halte ich das für keine utopie ich kann
mir vorstellen wenn die europäer klug
sind wenn sie weise sind wenn sie ihre
vorurteile hinter sich lassen dass wir
die möglichkeit haben an unseren
universitäten in unseren gesellschaften
eine europäische form eine moderne eine
aufgeklärte form von islam sich zu
entwickeln zu lassen die dann diese
geistige auseinandersetzung um die es
zentral geht erfolgreich bestehen kann
diese chance die sehe ich und es wäre
ein grosser jammer wenn wir die nicht
nutzen würden
unlängst hat genau in dieser sendung der
historiker philipp blom die
radikalisierten jugendlichen die einzige
radikale jugendbewegung in europa
genannt und ich komme gleich auf die
aktualität wenn ich noch einen moment
bei der historie bleiben darf um dem
nachzuforschen im film joschka fischer
von pepe danquart beschreiben sie sehr
offen und sehr genau wie sie das erlebt
haben das damals in frankfurt
straßenschlachten und irgendwann drehen
sie sich um und lassen sie sich nicht
nur von der polizei zusammen schlagen
sondern schlagen zurück und sie
beschreiben was das in ihnen verändert
hat und diese szene möchte ich schnell
zeigen
[Musik]
mit den besetzungen dann die
konfrontation mit der staatsgewalt
wir haben auf die mobilisierung
massenmobilisierung bis jetzt deswegen
häuserkampf aber auch dort eben einsatz
von gewalt unter dem gesichtspunkt dass
wenn wir angegriffen werden wir uns
perspektive es war eingreifen auch wir
an wenn es notwendig ist
es war natürlich ein sehr harte
auseinandersetzung von beiden sein
das war der punkt wo ich sah dass ein
einzelner hinter mir her kam und david
gesagt ich nicht mehr weg jetzt wenn ich
dem entgegen das war dann der
polizeimeister günther marx wenig später
feststellte und das war für mich ein
wendepunkt wenn man so will also wo ich
nicht mehr nur mich selbst sozusagen
angst hatte vor der staatsgewalt die vor
dem start zum ersten mal die angst auch
unter dem polizei helm und die anderen
haben dann hinterher aber das war auch
nicht was ich beabsichtigt hatte sondern
bei mir war es eher überwinden der
eigenen angst war das der moment der
quasi demokratischen läuterung
rechtsstaatlichen läuterung der sich auf
stoff vision eines kam später das kam
etwas später aber es war klar und der
überzeugung werde ich bis heute dass das
war der größte fehler sie dann sind sie
ganz aus dem aktivismus rau sein man
dann wurden sie heute aber nach dem
später sie haben noch einen moment
weiter naja das war geworfen später und
in politisch mussten sie einen preis
sein dass wollten ihnen viele zum strick
machen dann später diese gewalttätige
ist ja legitim wenn der demokratie
würdig umgekehrt auch versuchen und war
es knapp knapp dass die das nicht
geschafft haben sie daraus dass er nicht
ein wirkliches schicksals problem für
sie nicht wirklich nun also eine kleine
gruppe muss man sagen aber gewalttätige
gruppe ging dann in den terror in
deutschland diese bleiernen jahre wie
man es beschrieben hat wenn wir in die
aktualität zurückkommen aus syrien oder
nach syrien gehen anteil der
jugendlichen hier kommen dann
ausgebildet als terroristen zurück muss
was muss man tun mit syrien müsste man
sagen
auch jetzt ist noch der moment man
müsste auch den mut haben militärisch zu
intervenieren muss beendet werden und
das wird nicht gelingen wenn als hat auf
dauer an der regierung bleibt und wenn
der es dort weiter
sein unwesen treibt also wird man einen
ausweg einen diplomatischen ausweg
finden müssen für eine transformation
von assad hin zu einer regierung der
nationalen einheit dass es in wien
begonnen worden
und mit dem ass wird es ohne eine
militärische konfrontation nicht
weitergehen wobei das militär die lösung
nicht bringen wird sondern es ist diese
geistige die fast schon spiritueller
auseinandersetzung welche form des islam
wird sich durchsetzen
die traditionell konservative
wahabitisch saudi-arabische oder eine
moderne form des sunnitischen islams das
entscheidende frage aber gegen so
brutale truppen wie die dass er es soll
der westen sagen sie natürlich auch
eigene truppen schicken
ich sehe nicht dass der westen eigene
truppe effekt bisher war das entsenden
von truppen nicht gerade ein
erfolgsmodell und das hat sich jetzt
eine koalition gebildet die im
wesentlichen auf luftschläge setzt
ob es dabei bleibt kann ich ihnen nicht
vorhersagen aber ich sehe nicht dass die
usa an die müssen das machen größere
anzahl von bodentruppen in nahen osten
wieder engagieren wird dass sich und
wenn sie noch in der verantwortung
stünden würden sie das auch nicht
betreiben die cd wenn es dann gar nicht
anders geht dann müssen wir halt hin das
hängt vom konkreten fall aber ich würde
mir mehr als einmal nachdenken bevor ich
mich dafür einsetzen würde da deutsche
soldaten hin zu schicken kann mir auch
keine größere verantwortung und
belastung eines regierungspolitiker
vorstellen als die entscheidung ich
schicke truppen meines landes dorthin wo
ein machthaber ganze populationen
unterdrückt und aber das ist jetzt kann
man ja sagen genau das feld wo sie
geschichte geschrieben habe die frage
ist nicht nur ich meine wir sind ja
heute an erfahrung reicher
und es ist es reicht nur empört zu sein
es ist sehr wichtig moralisch empört zu
sein
das aber nicht zu reichen sondern die
frage die sich sofort stellt ist wenn
sie wo intervenieren welche ordnung wird
dort folgen oder wird es am ende noch
schlimmer was passiert ist
in libyen sind und insofern ist diese
frage die entscheidende frage mit der
empörung der moralischen berechtigten
empörung zusammen die beantwortet werden
muss durch die politik ist ein reicht
nicht ich meine wir haben es im irak ja
gesehen dort saddam hussein zu stürzen
denn nun wirklich ein brutaler gewalt
herrscher war aber die frage was dann
die wurde eben nie beantwortet war in
diesem sinne der konflikt im kosovo
milosevic gegen die albanische
population vorgegangen ist eine ganz
andere sie sind in die geschichte
eingegangen als der grüne minister der
aus seiner pazifistischen partei der
erste deutsche minister der sagt wir
sind dabei wir schicken truppen hat sie
das damals selbst ein bisschen den atem
geraubt diese historische verantwortung
ich war bevor ich überhaupt in die
bundesregierung persönlich eingetreten
bin entschieden und zwar wegen bosnien
im posten ereignet sich ja das
furchtbare verbrechen des massakers von
srebrenica wo mehrere tausend
muslimische männer und heranwachsende
männliche jugendliche von
der bosnisch serbische soldateska
ermordet wurden nach der einnahme der un
schutzzone srebrenica
das ist heute alles dokumentiert im
prozessakten und die geschichte ist
bekannt für mich war das der wendepunkt
wo ich mich selbst infrage stellen
musste weiß genau die debatte war die
ich mit der generation meiner eltern hat
warum habt ihr nicht trete und insofern
war ich entschieden das darf sich nicht
wiederholen kein zweites bosnien aber
für die partei war es natürlich ein
schwerer schritt denn wenn wir uns das
heute anschauen
die frage ist was kommt danach wurde ja
beantwortet im falle des westlichen
balkans ist die europäische perspektive
und ich hatte jüngst die gelegenheit an
einer diskussion in tirana teilzunehmen
im sommer und frühsommer und da saßen
sie alle die beteiligten staaten durch
ihre premierminister aufgereiht dass
auch der kosovarische premier minister
neben dem serbischen minister
das hatte für mich schon eine große
bedeutung weil es zeigte es ist etwas
möglich ein neuer politischer ordnung
hängt aber an der glaubhaftigkeit der
europäischen perspektive auch eine
gewisse genugtuung nehme ich dann an
wenn man sogar eine genugtuung es ist
zeigt es geht in die richtige richtung
mal wird es wird lange dauern aber das
steht und fällt der klapproth mit der
glaubwürdigkeit der europäischen
perspektive wenn die weg ist dann haben
wir dieselben probleme weder der film
den ich erwähnt habe joschka fischer
zeigt eigentlich auch sehr schön wie
hart die innenpolitische und die
auseinandersetzung in ihrer eigenen
partei
er war wie sie buchstäblich nun
angegriffen wurden und wie sie reagiert
haben darauf mit der vielleicht
wichtigsten vielleicht auch der westen
rede ihrer politischen laufbahn auch das
möchten wir
hat er allerdings und das muss man
verstehen die grünen sind eine mehrheit
eine pazifistische partei für die war
das natürlich ein eine eine zerreißprobe
ohne ende und dann kam es eben zum
bielefelder parteitag
wobei da gar nicht selbst fahren gar
nicht dass er die grünen als vielmehr
sollten das radikalere umfeld das sie
von den grünen schon längst getrennt
hatte und ja und dann bekam ich ein
verarbeiten aufs ohr da war ich wirklich
so was von sauer
ich wusste ich darf es nicht aber ich
hätte mir gerne gegriffen es waren viele
ex grüne da geht folgt ihrer krankheit
immer man von dem ganzen hardcore-fans
weideten sich da auseinandersetzung ob
da vielleicht die wichtigste rede in
meiner partei politischen laufbahn
erhalten
ich hatte schmerzen mit dem trommelfell
hab ziemlich wehgetan
ich war sauer
es war chaos pur
liebe freunde in neuen freunde liebe
gegner geliebte gegner ist er ein halbes
jahr sind wir jetzt hier in der
bundesregierung ein halbes jahr ja jetzt
kommen die ich habe nur darauf gewartet
kriegshetzer hier spricht ein
kriegshetze und herren die leute wird
schlag mit dem friedensnobelpreis vor es
ist krieg und ich hätte mir nie träumen
lassen dass rot grün mit dem krieg ist
aber dieser krieg geht nicht mehr zeit
haben 50 taten sondern seit 1992 liebe
freundinnen und freunde seit 1992
wir haben uns entschieden die
bundesregierung zu geben in einer
situation als klar war dass wir die
endgültige zuspitzung der jugoslawischen
erbfolgekrieges stattfinden kann
ich erinnere mich noch nein ich höre ich
auch denke fall durchläufen gefallen was
ich nicht bereit bin zu akzeptieren wie
den frieden setzt voraus dass menschen
nicht ermordet als menschen nicht
vertrieben das brauchen nicht
vergewaltigt werden dass er frieden
voraus ich stehe auf zwei grundsätzen
nie wieder krieg nie wieder auschwitz
nie gegen den völkermord nie wieder
faschismus beides gehört beim er
zusammen ich sage euch diese politik ist
in einem doppelten sinne verbrecherisch
ein ganzes volk zum kriegs hinzunehmen
zu vertreiben durch terror durch
unterdrückung durch vergewaltigung durch
ermordung und gleichzeitig die
nachbarstaaten zu destabilisieren
diese bezeichnet als eine
verbrecherische politik und ich weiß der
seriösen die emotionen
ich verstehe auch die argumente der
ablehnung jeder hat sie doch selbst in
sich ich höre diese diskussion
dafür tat im grunde genommen hier selbst
und jeder kürze und was ich euch als
außenminister bitte ist dass ich mir ein
herz da die unterstützung der untersee
möglich knüppel in die beine werfen und
da sie nicht geschwächt sondern gestärkt
aus diesem partei daraus geht um unsere
politik bei der vorletzten nicht
angehäuft
[Applaus]
da hat man den ganzen joschka fischer
den kämpfer den guten redner in drei
minuten gesehen löst das noch etwas aus
ihnen wenn sie das heute sehen weil es
ist vorbei ist es lange hin
abgeschlossen und aber war einer der
wichtigen moment den lahrer ohne jeden
zweifel ich meine die ironie des ganzen
war ja es ging ja nicht darum ob
deutschland sich an diesem krieg nicht
beteiligt oder nicht sondern ob rot grün
als regierung koalition bestehen bleiben
und das war der sehr sehr harte
entscheidung vor allem für meine partei
aber ich bin nach wie vor damals war die
richtige entscheidung getroffen
wir kommen schon bald zum schluss haben
sie das gefühl der joschka fischer der
einfachen die politik wollte weil er
fasziniert ist konnte dort auch etwas
ändern was sonst nicht so gekommen wäre
hat sie haben einen schönen satz mal
gesagt sie haben helmut schmidt fast
bedauert dass in den der mantel der
geschichte nicht so berührt hat wie er
willy brandt mit aus politik und wir
helmut kohl mit der wiedervereinigung
gerät hat sie der mantel der geschichte
ein bisschen berührt
ich habe nie nach dem wandel der
geschichte ausschau gehalten
ich kann es mir liegt an ihm vorstellen
wir hatten geschichte über reichlich wir
waren noch nicht in der regierung musste
man schon für ja oder nein zum krieg
entscheiden
mitten in regierungsbildung es ging dann
schlag auf schlag
dann war der balkan zu ende dann kam der
11 september
wo wieder alles auf den kopf gestellt
wurde afghanistan all das
das hörte nicht auf aber und man sie
nicht selber eine marke in der
geschichte hinterlassen
nein ein anderes unter die kanzler die
schauen doch ob sie dann in den
geschichtsbüchern gut stehen also müssen
wir den kanzler diskutieren weiß es
nicht
haben sie die nicht beobachtet so denn
ja aber ich glaube das wird aus
journalistischer perspektive überschätzt
man geht nicht in die politik und
geschichte zu machen
schon um dabei zu sein wenn sie gemacht
wird aber was ist jetzt mein beitrag
oder ähnliches mehr
das funktioniert nicht der eigene
historiker zu werden das hat noch nie
funktioniert wird nicht funktionieren
das muss man der nachwelt überlassen das
schöne dabei ist in der regel ist man
dann nicht mehr dabei kann von ford sein
genau also war viel hat es dabei sicher
viel spannendes viel leidenschaft schon
fast zum schluss zu in dieser
weihnachtszeit kurz vor weihnachten
möchten wir ihnen noch ein paar sekunden
lang freude machen mit svs wovon wir
glauben und zu glauben wissen dass es
ihn auch freude macht
sie erkennen es sofort als klassikfreund
naja
mozart
alfred brendel zunächst das konzert
glaube ich bei klassik das bedeutet
ihnen was aber das kam irgendwann
plötzlich ins leben die klassen ja ja in
einer schweren lebenskrise klartext ein
weiteres mal hat mich eine frau
zurückgelassen und wurden sie immer
verlassen sind ja die gerne und das war
ziemlich bitter und da war ich bei
meinem freund otto schily in seinem
italienischen haus eine woche gut für
mich und er hat eine große klassik
sammlung und da fing ich an klassik zu
hören und hatte plötzlich ein ohr dafür
was mich vorher nicht wirklich
interessiert und seither ist mozart ein
noch weiter weil vorher haben sie andere
musik gehört und ich habe gelesen dass
ein ganz andere musik als mozart einen
sehr großen einfluss auf ihr leben als
aktivist gehabt hat bob der bh hatte was
war die bedeutung von bob dylan für
joschka fischer freiheit alles hinter
sich zu lassen das eigene leben so zu
leben wie man es möchte
das würden sie heraus aus solchen
stücken sind sie richtig dass die erste
platte die ich überhaupt gekauft habe
war frivolen bob dylans blowin in the
wind drauf ist und hat trainer gerne
fordern diese sehnsucht nach weite und
ist noch geblieben oder jetzt hat
dagegen mozart keinen stich mehr der
dylan
doch ich mag ihn noch sehr wobei ich nie
ein konzert von ihm besucht warum der
tour jahren ja mal ein ding never ending
warum gehen sie nicht hin keine
motivation
was ist besser daran nicht mehr
politiker zu sein
schauen sie ich wollte nicht eine
sekunde missen
und so sehe ich mich über meine partei
geärgert habe oft und sie sich über mich
nehme ich an verdanke ich ihr
unglaublich viel
aber irgendwann war es genau ich habe
einen preis bezahlt für die große
politik der mir sehr hart an kam nämlich
den freiheits verlust der persönlichen
freiheit verlust um meine persönliche
freiheit wieder gewonnen zu haben warum
ist sein minister nicht fragen
vizekanzler
sie sind dort also vom persönlichen von
persönlichem zeitbudget her starts
sklave da wir stehen andere der gibt da
kein ich will nicht oder
sondern da gibt es ein eng getaktet das
zeitkorsett und sie müssen rücksicht
nimmt sie verantworten auch sehr viel
für andere kann ich einfach sagen aber
ich will das nicht mehr hören und jetzt
sind sie frei und nutzen das auch machen
wird beliebt lebe ich wieder das leben
wie ich es eigentlich mag
und wofür auch noch um in der welt als
familie für sie und der preis ja nichts
angetönt im privatleben denen man zahlt
viele beziehungen die zerbrochen sind
dokumentiert hat zwar gesagt herr
joschka fischer ist katholik der heirat
wird sowieso immer gleich wieder aber
war schon hart
ja ich will mich hier überhaupt nicht
selber bedauern es war mal eine freie
entscheidung und das wollte nicht eine
sekunde missen
aber mir war immer klar das ist soweit
es mich betrifft ein endliches sache und
wenn die möglichkeit eines anständigen
abschieds kommt dann werde ich den
nutzen
das ist gelungen der abgang da sind sie
zufrieden kann ich mich nicht beschweren
die wir hatten die wahlen verloren und
ich wollte dann raus aus der politik und
ich sehe mich darum steht schauen sie
ich habe mir eben und stoiber angeguckt
hat er es nötig gehabt sich von der
drittklassigen ehemalige csu-landrätin
abfeiern zu lassen es war wirklich nicht
nötig also man muss meines erachtens
auch irgendwann mal sagen so jetzt ist
gut die tür hinter sich zumachen den
schlüssel umdrehen und wegwerfen und
gemessen an der utopie die der junge
oskar hat das ist okay sie konnten
einiges erreichen wie sie es sich naja
schauen sie wenn sie sich
ich pflegte auf diese fragen immer zu
beantworten und ich finde dass nach wie
vor die richtige antwort in einer
gegenfrage
wo waren die grünen gefährlicher als sie
bei demonstrationen am bauzaun gerüttelt
haben oder als sie in der regierung
waren und das atomgesetz ändern konnten
mit rot grüner markt wo im zweiten lauf
bringt was so ändert man realität und
darauf können die grünen nun wirklich
stolz sein
ich meine die neue energiepolitik die
sie in deutschland durchgesetzt haben
die hat weitreichende konsequenzen und
folgen weil nicht nur der ausstieg
sondern auch der einstieg in die
erneuerbaren energien
das nehme ich als schlusswort und folge
daraus sie sind also nicht wie
shakespeares hamlet der gesagt habe die
zeit ist aus den fugen verfluchter hohen
dass ausgerechnet ich geboren wurde das
ding zurechtzurücken
sie haben das freiwillig und gerne
gemacht ich habe freiwillig und gerne
gemacht aber als ich der meinung war nun
ist es genug war es dann auch genug um
so auch richtig dann bedanke ich mich
beim bob dylan der deutschen politik der
weniger als hamlet oft gezögert hat und
mehr als die sich was ein paar steine
ganz den hang aufgebracht hat bedanke
mich herzlich für dieses gespräch
ich danke ihnen auch froh tage wünsche
wünschen wir ihnen auch sie herzlich und
jetzt geht es dann gleich weiter mit
kunst wird zeigen die vierte folge der
animationsserie die abenteurer der
modernen kunst über das pariser künstler
leben nach 1900 sowie tom brady gasse
und
bleiben sie dran und ansonsten einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]